[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 148 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Randall and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work yes again after a
short hiatus how you doing Melanie hi
mark welcome back welcome back to you
too I think we've both for traveling a
whole lot yes we were and I know last
week you were a little tied up over in
Tokyo where were you in Tokyo what were
you up to so yeah I was over in Tokyo I
was at cloud next presenting at the
inside version of cloud neck so the game
conference that was like a little side
thing on the cloud next it was a pretty
awesome event I was really great I think
there were thousands of people lots of
cloud people from Tokyo and I also
learned something very important I
didn't realize this but their local GCP
community is called CF bug so just use a
group and they have a logo with a pug
inside Dex gone and it's a poke it's
awesome so that's a group I need to be
involved in yes I have a sticker on my
laptop now a nice well so overall it was
a great experience it sounds like and
I'm glad he's fantastic I'm glad you
made it back I was in Java yeah you say
last week we were sharing the episode we
recorded in Stellenbosch Africa which
was at deep learning in Java and it was
great and one thing I forgot to mention
last week was that one of the awards
that was given out for the best posters
was Google cloud platform credits we
gave out $2,000 worth of credits for 25
different posters so it's really great
and I'm glad we were able to do the
podcast and record from there we have a
couple more podcast that will be sharing
out later next month and thank you to
you Melanie for taking care of the
podcast while I was in Japan I really
appreciate it it was fun for anybody who
wants to know the difference between a
South African accent and an Australian
accent we should listen to last week's
episode and then all the other episodes
compare anyways we had it we had some
help from a few folks over there
so mark what's going on this week so
this week we're bringing back a
interview that we did while we were at
next earlier this year so the next in
San Francisco this time we had a great
discussion with the team from Willie Oh
with Siobhan and Eric talking about all
the data science things they do over at
Willie oh it was really really cool it
was it was a full picture
it was the nice thing it seemed like
applied machine learning but from the
start to the end from
coming up with the concept and the
problem and then actually to the
deployment it was really valuable
interviewing so I'm glad we're finally
gonna get a chance to share that with
everyone yeah yeah really great one and
then we have a question of the week of
this afternoon we're gonna step away
from the GCP side of things and move
back maybe a little to the Google cloud
so we did hear that inbox is going away
which makes me very sad but we're gonna
talk about what can we do with the Gmail
features that we moved across and talk a
little bit about that and like what sort
of things you can use once inboxes : yes
how to move forward with Gmail and as
Ian hooks cuz we're gonna have a therapy
session it's all good
alright so as always we start off with
our cool things of the week we have a
couple things that are generally
available now data studio and data prep
so data studio being this great bi tool
that we've been providing it's working
with more than 500 data sources and more
than 100 partner built connectors and
it's used by over a million people it's
it's a pretty well used tool that's out
there in terms of business intelligence
and data prep of course allowing you to
prepare your data when you're doing any
type of analysis or machine learning
with it there's a lot of work sometimes
you have to do to clean it up and the
data prep tool allows you to do that and
now that it's generally available it's
got a new look it allows for things like
team collaboration and some additional
features so yeah those are nice that is
nice yeah
and speaking of generally available we
also have cloud memory store for Redis
going generally available so if you're
looking for a manager reddest system you
can come to us for that as well and we
also expanded it to several new regions
so now cloud memory store is supported
in Tokyo Singapore in the Netherlands
which are new as well as Aragon Iowa
South Carolina Belgium and Taiwan Thanks
another cool thing of the week I know
earlier this year in May we were talking
about the Coursera courses that came out
for tensorflow and these were the
machine learning with tensorflow a
Google cloud platform course that's a
five course specialization and it's like
now in the top ten data science
specializations on Coursera that's out
there following on to that they went
with a more advanced machine learning
with tensorflow
course that has been released recently
and this advanced course covers topics
like end to end machine learning with
tensorflow a Google cloud platform
production machine learning systems
image understanding with tensorflow a
Google Cloud sequence models for time
series and natural
language processing and recommendation
systems with tensorflow
so this is something that will help take
you another step down the path of
expanding your machine learning
expertise and there's going to be a
webinar on October 9th at nine am to
learn more about the course fantastic
speaking of machine learning as well
teammates of ours Sarah Robinson and
Zach Akal recently released a blog post
on the Google cloud blog called
simplifying ml predictions with Google
cloud functions this is a really great
hands-on a lot post that takes you
through all the code that they use to
write cloud functions : cloud ml from
the cloud function and going all the way
through it's actually a really great
read yes it is and it's great to get
this out from our teammates yes the last
thing we want to mention is that Mark
Moore gave us a shout out as one of the
50 best cloud security podcasts in an
article that he wrote and he gave us a
nice little overview in terms of some of
the podcast episodes in particular that
he found especially useful and one of
those of course being event surf episode
which I agree was a very valuable
episode that you guys captured last year
thank you very much for including us in
your list it was much appreciated thank
you all right mark I think it's time for
us to go and talk with Willie oh yeah I
think we did enough cool things of the
week let's go talk with well yeah yes so
it's day three here at next and it's the
final interview but super excited we
have two wonderful people with us I'm
gonna probably Massacre your names but
we'll try our very best
Savan Aldo Norman yes wonderful VP of
data science at Willie oh and Eric a
drink oh yes am I gonna do really well
yeah also CTO of Willie oh I thank you
so much for joining us and taking time
out of necks to come hang out with us
yes yeah awesome we want to hear all
about what you're doing it well Leo how
you do it like well how all this stuff
works basically but you want to tell us
a little bit about who both you are and
what it is you do is fine you wanna go
first sure so my name is Yvonne and it's
a nice Israeli name Hebrew name Hebrew
month my backgrounds in statistics so I
have a master and a PhD in the
the statistics world and I was intrigued
in applying statistics to temporal
spatial models so that's where I started
my career and I worked for several years
in the agriculture technology space
alongside Eric actually and after
several years there I transitioned to
well yo and in well yo we work on the
food technology space which is kinda in
a similar space right they're related to
each other but one tackles more the
demand side and the other the supply
side so after several years in the
supply side of food I really wanted to
move to the demand because if you want
to change supply you really should just
change demand that's much easier so I
joined well yo and I've been developing
models for and recommendation systems
for food and I think will tell you a
little bit more about well in a minute
but yeah I build models for life I am a
super duper happy statistician data
scientist slash machine learner and all
the words above the describe the same
position and you like chocolate and I
love dark chocolate correct I'm Eric I'm
CTO and co-founder of dwelle Oh my
background is very similar just Vons in
some ways I'm I'm trained as a computer
scientist I did a PhD actually in pure
math I think of myself as a
disillusioned mathematician I got a
little tired of staring at the wall and
wanted to do something a little more
impactful so I came out to the Bay Area
and I've been working in machine
learning ever since
and while the Oh kind of grew out of a
personal problem that I had that I think
is shared by many people which is to
feed my family at home healthy meals and
make good decisions about food and ways
to make eating at home the the easiest
and healthiest choice and especially
when making decisions under dressed like
with a crying kid and hungry that's
exactly the moment when I want machines
to make decisions for me because I know
I won't make a good one and I had all
this exposure to technology that was
helping make nutrition decisions for
plans but I had none of that technology
for my own
and so I wanted to create the experience
of having a personal chef nutritionist
in the house to help with meal planning
and grocery shopping and those sorts of
things and I imagined a way in which
that could be embodied in an intelligent
machine so that's that's kind of how how
we got to here when we talk about well
yeah we talk about how can we make
personalized family nutritionist
available to everyone in the world not
just someone that can afford it we both
have families I have two kids so we
we've tackled the problem of like how do
you feed everyone in the family how do
you personalize it I'm gonna diet my
husband likes these kind of foods my
kids don't eat these types of foods so
how do we really cook at home so that
everyone's happy everyone's healthy and
also like the other side is how do we
make people learn the relationship
between food and their well-being which
is very hard it's very hard to know and
you look at trends of how people have
thought about diets over time it's it
changes right one decade it's you need
more vitamin C in the next decades it's
vitamin D and like Oh eat more meat eat
less meat there's not a lot of
consistent science in this domain and
definitely not very hard to personalize
that domain and that's sort of the the
problem we're trying to tackle
well how does well work that's a very
good question so there's two things to
Elio there's the technology platform
which is really ultimately designed to
be an AI for food if you excuse the buzz
words for this type of audience yeah
what is it what is the user experience
look like yeah and so on top of that
user experience one user experience
we're testing in the market today is
it's essentially a virtual culinary
assistant so you say something like I
would like to eat shrimp tacos tonight
and then it knows oh you probably want
corn tortillas because there's someone
in the house is gluten-free you like
these brands you need this number of
servings you'll probably like this
recipe but it needs to be modified a
little bit to make it spicy less spicy
reduced the fat content to increase the
protein content something like that and
the system goes out translates that high
level request into a specific grocery
order it executes the grocery order for
you and then through one of our partners
we do
about your groceries and customized
recipes to you the same day so it
translates a high-level intents into
dinner tonight and what markets do you
serve right now we're not publicly
available although you can sign up for
our data list and we can currently serve
about 60% of the US market we're mostly
limited on availability of delivery
partner and we we partner with Amazon
fresh and stick hard people people like
that to actually do the last mile on
delivery nice but so in terms of data
science how does data science play a
role into this so from minute zero data
and data science played a really big
role so I think you can imagine you can
build this company two ways one is you
can start with very limited meals bring
an expert in the domain like a chef and
start creating very tiny old recipes and
start promoting those recipes and over
time you would increase your database
and make it bigger and and learn intent
and so on and so on we did not go that
path we didn't feel that's a scalable
path and really from the get-go we said
we really want to understand the
culinary space and in the food space and
in order to do that from like as a data
scientist what you first need is a big
dataset and so we went out and got a
vast amount of data recipe data for
example and blog data from food and
articles on food and we generated a
gigantic database with food related
information and then we could start
training models on top of it and when
Eric says like translate intent to a
shopping list and doing all of that
there's a lot of models that come into
play from you know taking this
unstructured data whether it's the
intent or even if you think about the
data that we've accumulated like if you
look at recipe data from different
varieties and you really think about you
know not a single website but many many
websites its unstructured data so the
first thing you have to do is apply a
some way to structure it and we took a
very machine learning deep learning
approaches
and we structure it using models and
once the data is structured then you can
start building recommendation systems
and top of them that would recommend
what recipe how to adapt the recipe
personalize it to a certain person or a
family even like how to make it into a
shopping list so now that you have a
recipe how do you personalize the
shopping list maybe its particular
stores that people like or brands or
particular items that they prefer
organic for example or traditional so
all these personalization on top is
another part where the machine learning
and data science comes in right where
does your data cut from the data is
comes from proprietary sources and also
from the web got it so it's combo so
whinger when you're doing and this is
maybe my naive understanding of the
machine learning side of things but when
you're doing these deep modal analysis
of like the data that you have you
essentially like categorizing it so that
people can use it or like tagging it or
there's different level of structuring
so when you think of a recipe you can
think of ingredients and preparation
lines so one type of structure is to
take for example ingredient line and
extracting certain information from that
alone like for example if it says one
cup of sugar you would need to know that
sugar is the actual food entity that was
in that in line and the cup is the
amount and one is I or the unit of
measure and one is the amount so one is
structuring that kind of structuring and
yeah which is kind of annotation things
like that and the other one is driving
additional labels so for example cuisine
type or the type of course or things
like that so that's another type of
models that you know classification
models that we have to develop and
you're right yeah and I mean there's
some other things that we've done that
we're very interesting they're more on
the the latent semantics space so for
example on top of this parsing of
recipes you now have a data set where
you have co-occurrence of food terms so
parmesan and tomatoes co-occur quite
frequently for some reason and you can
actually build essentially something
just like we're Tyvek you can build
vector representations of these food
terms and the vector representations
capture culinary use so if you look in
the vector space for things that are
very close to parmesan you find all of
the
other Italian cheeses Reggiano etc etc
and so by kind of taking this even
semi-structured data and then using some
of the techniques we all know and love
you can get pretty rich representations
that you can then use as good signals or
features for other Michigan learn models
that maybe are more yeah for example
ingredient substitutions you can think
about it that way right you can think of
generative recipes all sorts of these
kind of applications on top of it are
you doing generative recipes I would not
say that we've conquered generative
recipes you're exploring and we explore
yeah especially from ingredients I know
for people who you know they may have a
certain types of ingredients in their
house and some of these recipes can be
very like a barrier to entry sometimes
with some of the ingredients they ask
for it's nice when you can see what's
easy to swap yeah I mean there's also
very practical things because often
times you go to the grocery store and
the grocery store themselves don't know
what inventory they have yeah
and they may have run out of the thing
that you intended to buy so you need to
make a decision in the moment about what
to do right and so ok once you've got
the data set for the food essentially in
the ingredients and the recipes I'm
guessing there's another side which is
like the consumers wants and needs and
like how do you mush the two things
together yeah that's the personalization
step right so we there's kind of two
types that Eric mentioned when you sort
of describe the journey one is more
about like the type of things I like my
taste I like these types of recipes or
I'm following a certain diet right and
paleo or keto babies there's the health
conditions that could sort of also
dictate certain things and then there's
like like that's more on the food domain
when you ask people and then there's
more on the shopping domain right which
is like what kind of stores do I like to
shop in and what kind of grocery items
do I usually buy but my budget is I have
other kind of constraints that may come
in or what do I have in my pantry and
how do I you know bring it or I dislike
these types of like I hate pickles so if
you should you know if you bring me a
recipe with pickles you're gonna have
some recommend some alternatives to
those pickles so there's all these
information some of it we can ask
directly a lot of other companies do
like very very directly right like a
diet are you on a specific
it dislikes and likes things like that
and others I think we've taken a more
different approach like for example
taste for me people can describe what
they like but it's much easier and maybe
much more informative to not ask it
directly but indirectly by asking them
to choose a set of recipes from a list
or to learn it over time because they're
selecting more and more recipes so you
can over time adapt to their tastes
better or explore their tastes varieties
that they like as opposed to asking if
you prefer savory or sweet or things
like that that people may say it but
they they may not always exactly want
that one thing they may want to venture
out so some things we collect very
directly by asking and others kind of
indirectly through the interaction with
the app itself yeah that makes sense I'm
just thinking like if you asked me
directly what movies I watch I would
probably tell you odd house because I am
cultured but if I'm at home I'm probably
watching Terminator 2 so this is great
what are some of the GCP products that
you're using I think it may be easier to
say what should you see probably sure
yeah that's a new one let's try that
what are we not using big we're not
using a big table that's about it okay
Wow everything we're not using a big
table we're not using spanner do you use
TP use oh why don't we why don't we
start when we start on the journey and
where you started which is like the data
side of things so we're like where does
that data go and how do you process it
yes actually so the first thing we did
build was the crawling system because
I'm a data scientists I've worked with
many data scientists I've never met a
data scientist who didn't want more data
so I figured we better have data if
we're going to be successful so we built
a crawling system that's built in Python
the actual operations of it is heavily
influenced by the availability of things
like gke
that runs on gke auto scales on gke and
all of the data coming out of that is
dumped on to GCS and then all of the
post-processing happens via pub/sub so
that there's various stages of goes
through kind of a stage pipeline that's
all coordinated by by pub/sub in there
is gke clusters that read the messages
and this is stored on bigquery even when
it's unstressed yeah there's there's
some yeah there's a whole bunch of side
channels that are this pipelining week
we collect data at various levels of
normalization that is available on GCS
in some rare form which we can then
access and we do access via data prompt
but primarily it ends up in bigquery and
then most of the machine learning either
kind of in an ad hoc or in a more formal
repeated training we are using data
practice more like a Hadoop or with a
spark or with spark yeah actually we're
increasingly kind of automating a lot of
our model training evaluation and
deployment pipelines on Composer tell us
about composer because I think that's
very new in fact I have no idea to this
composer is that's essentially an
orchestration where it's it's hosted
airflow the airflow seems to have been
widely increasingly widely used in the
industry for doing machine learning
pipelines where I have step AI transform
some data step B I maybe need to train a
model the next step is maybe I do model
evaluation and then model selection and
then I need to deploy it so if you want
to run model training on some schedule
like that we've been doing that recently
and in composer and that's worked very
well there's a lot of nice hooks for
some of the other GCP offerings for
instance like cloud ml inge and we use a
lot of cloud ml engine with caras
actually increasingly and we launched
our training jobs directly from composer
as we get new data coming in new label
data or new unstructured data depending
on the pipeline yeah and we do have
several models that really are kind of
continuous integration development and
deployment in the sense that we've
developed them we train them we get all
of that from composer and then there's a
human in the loop that once the output
of the model is
schon we have an internal tool that
which show the model output internally
in our team we have experts domain
experts chefs and and people in the
culinary space that would review the
labels of the that the model produced
for example like we talked about it
could say that some type of cuisine or
things like that and they would correct
and we would collect that corrected data
and then we can sort of train again the
model with more data so that over time
the mall improves in monitor we can
monitor that improvement so we
definitely have kind of those mechanisms
that's actually really interesting so
you're not you're not just ml and as you
said before you were like we're not just
doing a human it's kind of the
combination of both I think that
companies do that too yeah I think we
even with our experience from our
previous company it's very clear to us
that machine learnings and models and I
guess that's also my backgrounds like I
cannot in good conscience have a model
that I believe will always be right
there's always going to be cases where
models are me wrong and as Eric cited as
the data scientist I've always gonna
want more data so having experts in the
room talking to you helping you
understand the data and like I would
admit I before coming to Elio but I am
NOT a chef and I am NOT an expert in
this domain so having best domain expert
sit next to me and asking lots of
questions about the data so that I
understand how to properly utilize it
really helps and so yeah we've devised
the mechanism so that we can you know
kind of get the most from this domain
expert and scale in some sense when the
data's being flowed through your your
ETL and and through the data and doing
the training is it badge is it streaming
is it a mix it's it's yeah it's a mix
it's primarily batch today especially in
the training side I think going forward
will be more online and streaming we do
do streaming in an other way too which
we do by human the loop in that is to
have human loop kind of operationally so
we have a system where
a model will be selecting a grocery list
say for an individual and then the model
will also output some confidence scores
with respect to the the rankings it's
made in terms of the grocery items and
then if that falls below some threshold
we actually will shunt some of that work
to human expert and the human expert can
review and override some of the model
based decisions that's entirely
streaming that process yes I would say
like we have sufficient data that we
don't get a lot from training online
like from every observation
I probably do need you know enough
quantity to sort of move the needle
again as the needle is already quite
high so to move it again takes a while
and so I think this system that Eric
describes helps us deal with outliers
and things that don't work all the way
it's like it should because they're
outlier and and it will take time for
the machine learning to sort of go get
all those kind of edge cases and I'm
also curious in terms of your setup do
you are you using from the more like
data engineering side of things
stick driver and other performance tools
yeah yeah to make sure it's yeah systems
functioning the way I wanted to and Eric
said you know ask us what we're not
using it's actually right it's probably
true you know there's a presentation
with all the Google icons in them yeah I
think we can highlight many many of the
icons that we use we're really not just
the data science but those are the
engineering side very adventurous and
up-to-date with the current technology
that Google is offering so that we can
adapt quickly and move fast and I think
we've been really really good at like
you know I know a lot of beta like
composer and other things that are in
pure beta that we are like really
adapting already into our stack I was
guy got excited in this conference to
hear more about Club function in
bringing Python into the mix of it so
eager to test that in our infrastructure
we don't have that yet but definitely
other components from Google have made
it very easy as a data scientist to sort
of explore data push models into
production
been a really nice platform to work with
and you mentioned some of the models
that you're working with their
recommender well a lot of these end up
being some form of recommendation or
classification anyways but are you it
sounds like you're using ml engine or
you said you're in using ml engine so
you're using neural nets that some are
yeah some are like deep learning Nets
and some are I like to call them shallow
models now that everyone really loves
the buzzwords of deep deep muscles so
yeah we use a combination of shallow and
deep model depending on the application
but a lot of it
we talked about we have like these
semantic representation of certain
things and then we might train a more
shallow model on top of it right so like
transfer learn and things like that so
we have a combo of these approaches are
you using other things like random
forests and linear regressions based on
the types of other problems that you're
working on yeah this would be it's a
combination I really am NOT I'm trained
as a statistician so my I rather be and
I'm practical some a mic okay what is
the right approach for this problem and
I don't believe the deep learning is the
solution to all of the problems in the
world I believe that you know you need
to understand the data you to understand
what you're trying to solve sometimes
simple approaches can get you what you
need in order to solve the the business
problem it tends to be a very layered
approach in that like the models that
are consuming essentially unstructured
data that that could be raw text that
could be images for example tend to be
different networks and then they output
some vector representation or some
additional auxilary data or labeling and
then can be fed into an
application-specific model and sometimes
that model is a deeper neural network
but very often it's not how are you how
are you serving these models like how do
you end up using them at the end yeah we
serve them well we have a microservices
architecture and so everything for the
most part ends up in gke in some form of
another we are starting to increasingly
use cloud ml engine as a deployment
platform
when we can I'm excited to try that with
more frameworks than tensorflow we've
we've done that with tensorflow I'm
excited to try that outside attention
flow because we we like to think about
the models we produces essentially
appliances and then the engineering
organization can just use them as any
other service it's just another API that
you call we're a very small team we have
no platform engineering team GCP is our
platform engineering team is so we we
either have none or we have a giant one
depending on how you look at it and we
have no operations team everyone is kind
of owns operations and that includes all
the data scientists so all the machine
learning operations online models
monitoring performance monitoring to
stackdriver for example that's all done
by yeah yeah so that's really
interesting and you're using a lot of
very different pieces of GCP but you're
you're all learning it with a small team
you facing any challenges about like
basically using so many things or you
want to get nice or how's that
experience like well I mean you know
some things are kind of new I think to
the data science industry in some ways I
mean most times will we talk to other
data scientists they're not super
familiar kubernetes for example so
that's just new but I think what we
found it's very nice is that the the
abstraction layer is a GCP seem to be
well considered in that you don't have
to relearn API primitives or
command-line interfaces over and over
again you use different parts of the
system there's a fair amount of
consistency and so once our our
engineers or data scientists kind of
drop the underlying you know conceptual
space using it has to be it has to be
pretty
and there's some learning right that you
need to do in order to ramp up on
different technologies but I feel like
like I never worked on the Google cloud
platform before joining well yeah and
yeah it took it took a while but not as
much as it took me other platforms
that's a good good thing two different
questions I want to ask it earlier
before you're saying you want to try to
make it accessible outside of tensorflow
is there a reason why you you want to be
able to explore beyond tons of flow and
is there a specific software that you'd
be more interested in well i Silvan was
saying ah recording for shallow models I
love this brand name by the way
say constantly shallow and deep I find
it very funny that people are judgment
now there's no alternative so for our
non deep neural network models and
primarily scikit-learn and so be able to
deploy those as individual wrestle
interfaces would be would be very useful
it's like it learns very popular yes yes
so I can't learn is very popular I think
we could do both of those and then that
allows us also to do model versioning so
that we can do a/b testing or canary
deployments that's something we want to
do more of and it provides a safety net
so that we can more quickly deploy new
models to production and we don't have
to be so careful in terms of the testing
but we can deploy monitor and then we
have the safety to rollback if we need
to and you were saying how it took a
little bit of time to get up to speed
any tips or tricks or advice for those
who are exploring GCP for the first time
trying to build out their own solutions
for their company so I was like in a
bigger company before so in a bigger
company data scientist at least in my
experience they really have a very
specific role they don't really do the
data engineering that's done by someone
else they're very very data science
meaning you build you know you look at
the data you build a model and you push
it to someone else and I think my
biggest problem was like oh I now need
to learn all the data engineering side
because no one's gonna do it for me oh I
need to learn DevOps is there's no
DevOps team oh I need to do all of these
things so it was more tackling those
things I think from a data science
perspective like if my role in this
company was just look at data develop
models and push it this platform makes
it extremely easy to do those tasks
really like accessing the data in
different formats from different
locations it's become extremely easy and
simple spinning up your own notebooks to
be able to explore the data from
different places is very easy deploying
in the model now becomes extremely easy
- with cloud ml so it's a platform
that's designed in some sense for data
scientists to play around with I think
it becomes more challenging when you're
like yeah you know you're also the
engineer and the DevOps so you need to
learn about kubernetes and you need oh
yeah you do need to understand all these
things then it becomes a little bit more
complicated
you also mentioned earlier that you are
using TP use how are you using TP use
for training purposes yeah well one
thing that's very important for us is to
think about our biggest costs and our
biggest cost is opportunity cost and
that way we don't have an infinite
number of software engineers so if a
software engineer is doing an X they're
not doing Y and that means especially
for people building and building models
that the faster they can get to the next
iteration result of better so that is
reducing training time and we use
accelerators and CPUs and GPUs for
reducing time to answer and the other
thing that we increasingly use which has
been very beneficial for us is the hyper
parameter optimization yeah so used to
be that we would have these long
discussions you know it's Gian people
thought that their job as a data
scientist was to know and have intuition
about what type of primers to choose and
now I tell them I don't really worry
about that we'll just run a big
experiment and I'd rather have the
experiment running than spend another
couple days thinking about which
parameter should be you what's the issue
there for people who aren't familiar
with that space when you build say take
a deep neural network you have to decide
how many layers you should have how many
how big each layer should be which which
units you have in each layer you could
choose from different units activation
function I mean there's a smorgasbord of
like it the way I like to explain it and
I'm just gonna jump in with this is it's
almost like everyone's very complex you
know radios that you can tune all the
things for the radio to make this
sound like a certain quality she got to
be an expert on how to tune it and that
can be a challenge
yeah that can be a challenge in the
alternative to be an expert is you know
what the Machine worry about that
because then you can go on to doing
things that I think are higher value
which is what what problems should would
be solving which we work should we
prioritize which a new model should we
build and let the platform do the
fine-tuning I think we've seen the same
thing by the way with feature
engineering and I've had discussions
with data scientists even Googlers data
scientist who they told me that they
they think their job is getting
automated away because their job used to
be to look at some raw data and then
they could figure out how to encode the
raw data and these features that would
work well in a Michigan learn law and
now with deep neural networks the
network does most of the encoding and it
does a better job of encoding the raw
input and most data scientists do so
that data scientist job is no longer to
be a feature engineering and I think the
next phase is the data scientist job is
not going to be to be choosing hyper
parameters and then it's probably going
to be not to be choosing model
architectures well and that starts to
touch into Auto ml to which have you
explored that yet
a little yes that's on the list of
things we have years we've done what we
like we tried once or twice there might
be good use cases for it and I agree
that some automation is good but maybe
like my own internal thing is like I
want to see the model I need to see the
actual like architecture and what it
does and I believe in the technology of
deep learning I understand it
mathematically understand where it's
going but I also like believe that the
value of a data scientist is and
interpreting some of these things
sometimes and the more deep learning is
applied the less people have an
understanding even the people who
actually develop these models have that
less understanding of what's going on
internally what are the actual features
it's creating how to like explain it to
anyone the causal things that people
like to interpret with causality becomes
really hard so I think it with Auto ml
it's even more obscure than normal I see
a lot of benefit for certain places
especially if you want to accelerate
certain things that are very
common tasks and machine learning then
you should use it because there's you
don't need to hire today like a whole
suite of data scientists just to build a
model of every plague that's already
kind of implemented for you right and it
takes away that magic of like feature
selection and all of these things so I
think it's very useful for those kind of
use cases you feel like if you have a
data scientist and they know what
they're doing letting them play around
the tensorflow and building models that
you can better grasp when they fail and
when they're good it's good for the
organization so this is why I guess Eric
and I are good pairing as he pushes in
that direction and I push in the other
direction so on average it's fine
excellent well in one other thing on the
TPU side do you combine those with GPUs
and CPUs and the calculations in the
computations that you're doing yeah
that's one thing that I would say is
still a challenge for us which is when
you have a particular model training job
having to decide the compute
infrastructure because sometimes is
actually especially in dollar terms that
that requires a lot of trial and error
on our part I'd love to be able to just
set a budget I would like to train this
model for this many dollars and be able
to trade off time to convergence and
it's a good product to build yeah
because yes sir yeah because what we do
now is we will run a job and we'll use
just CPU distributed CPU training and
then we'll compare that with a single
GPU and then you can you choose your
flavors of GPUs or GPU and then we have
to decide for that class of models which
one we think we should use as the
standard in our composer workflow which
is doing the automated training that's a
very like operational optimization
decision that that most I think most
data scientists probably don't want to
do but like I've seen talks in this
conference talk a lot about the
engineering costs in a less focus about
these topics of like oh how much does it
take to train your model it's more about
if you have an app where should you
deploy it and how much it will cost you
or like operationally what's going on
and I think this this is kind of an area
that hasn't yet been fully explored
maybe well not that's point what have
you seen it next that you've been
excited about
that you're interested in looking into
further we actually we made a list yes
just before coming here without knowing
that this is going to be questioned and
there were quite a few things so I got
really excited about cloud functions I
can see immediate benefits and I like
that there's a Python beta version so
I'm like okay we we might want to try
that we might want to venture into that
there's some Google vision that we
looked at though we were like oh we
might be able to capitalize on it
there's some really cool new things that
were shown there I actually went to an
amazing talk that maybe is not new but
just explained it in a better way it was
like a DevOps advocator but she was one
of the keynote speakers today
she talked yesterday with kind of tips
for DevOps for people who are not DevOps
and I would like it's gonna be on
YouTube I heard so that one it was a
very very good talk and so I'm excited
to take some of the learnings she
suggested there I was telling Eric there
was a talk about traffic director we
googled it and couldn't find it so
there's an alpha version of something
called traffic director it co and and it
works for with in voi so all of these
things were like oh those are
interesting things we should start
thinking about and then the last one was
the firestore stuff that were mentioned
and threw out lots of things here and
next we're talking about firestore so I
thought there's some nifty ideas on how
you kind of immediately go from
firestore into bigquery and other kind
of storages so that the data can can get
shown more quickly to the data
scientists into the models so I'm kind
of excited about 32 so lots of things
you know you're ender is that the entire
list it's pretty similar I mean I think
we're increasingly as a business
providing our platform to partners and
that means giving them access to api's
and that creates kind of additional
operational needs so I'm really excited
by this teo in terms of talks in kind of
ways to use kubernetes well the
developer keynote Kelsey Hightower talk
was pretty awesome mister actually I had
the chance to a few weeks ago
serendipitously power program with them
at the end of dinner for 15 minutes and
I can say that the talk is exactly like
the pair programming experience so so
I'm excited to be able to use more of
the operational elements things like
this - and spinnaker I kind of really
extend gke as an Operations platform and
be able to do less operations especially
as we do b2b integrations fantastic well
before we wrap up today
is there anything we've missed or
anything you want to make sure that
listeners know about are you hiring only
eat dark chocolate above a certain
percent otherwise the experience is very
good and don't eat a hundred percent
because that's also very bad yes that's
one very important tip we are hiring
we're looking for back-end engineering
slash data engineering to join my team
so definitely that we also have in your
application developer so definitely
people on the spectrum and I think if
you're generally interested in the food
tech space it would be great to get in
touch with us I'm gonna assume the email
is gonna be somewhere visible and so we
would be always happy to talk to people
who are passionate about the space and
have opinions even if they're not
technology kind of people that's thank
you well thank you both for joining
thank you yeah thanks yeah so thanks
again to see Ron and Eric for joining us
on the podcast this was a great episode
so glad that you had the time to sit
down with us at next and really share
your knowledge with how well I was built
it was really awesome great and I think
that wraps it up for our next interview
smiley so thank you for being our last
but definitely not the least episode to
be able to share with everyone okay mark
let's talk about inbox inbox is gonna be
going away in the next six months is my
understanding and so there's been a lot
of work to make sure some of the
features and functionality that inbox
has has been moved over to Gmail so what
does that look like yes that's a good
question so first Melanie are you an
inbox user I have been I am definitely
an inbox user how do you feel I
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
most of everything's been moved across
the only feature that that I would like
to see move across if anyone's listening
I would love tea bundles move across if
that happens then I'm fine they do say
that there's some more additional
features they're working on bringing
over but I agree that in inbox this news
feature was my favorite and so when that
came into Gmail part it made it easier
for me to start adopting Gmail again
yeah so definitely yeah inbox inbox is
my life inbox is my to-do list so there
is yes March 2019 inbox is being
shutdown was a wonderful experiment and
so they're moving a lot of the features
over which is really good and a lot of
the features have been moved over as
well there is a transition guide that
has been written so if you're looking
for like snoozing of emails yep we can
do that which is really good because yes
snoozing is the best you can work
offline yeah you can do stuff offline
which is awesome too though I do
particularly appreciate coming back to
Gmail the new smart replies I really
like that so yes we've got a transition
guide that we're gonna link for everyone
to see what types of features have been
brought over to Gmail so you can have an
understanding of how that will look how
that will work yeah and pretty much
everything has been moved over right
like reminders if you use those which I
do
moving over to Google Tasks is pretty
seamless so just move that stuff across
which is pretty good likes news is still
there you can replicate bundles with
using tags and filters so it's not it's
not the end of world it's not the end of
the world I'm okay it's not the end of
the world and we highly recommend
everyone's if you are using inbox and
start taking a look at Gmail again and
see how that is transformed yeah you
might actually not recognize it because
it did go through a big redesign a
little while ago yeah and there's a lot
of really cool features in there all
right mark where you're gonna be what
you up to you and I are gonna be in
strange loop in we are in basically on
the day this comes out I think I'm
flying in leather than you are yes I
know you're a little bum cuz you're
missing out on the museum party that
they do every year yeah apparently
people want to meet me and talk to me
about stuff so yes I okay we'll be late
I am a little sad but why are you gonna
be late basically internal games meeting
stuff is basically the reason I'm
chairing our internal game summit that's
fun yeah it's good it's gonna be awesome
it's gonna be awesome and strangelet
will be really wonderful too and we're
planning on recording a podcast there
that we will share soon so you'll hear
more about that later and Mark anywhere
else you're gonna be in the next month I
don't think so I think October is going
to be relatively quiet there is a chance
that I will be UNITA that's probably
where I will be I have no idea what I'm
doing there or what I'm doing but it
seems likely that I'll probably beat you
not la are you going anywhere I am I'm
going to be in Portland Maine a week
after strangely if I'm going to be
speaking at mock Tober fest oh cool yeah
should be fun all right mark I think
that's it for us for this week I think
so too so Melanie thank you so much for
joining me if you get another episode of
the podcast thank you and thank you all
for listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]